question came in, can you measure glutamate levels? No, you can't. Well, I should say, yes, there
are neurotransmitter testing kits. So you can measure the neurotransmitter levels. And on those
neurotransmitter testing kits, you will see glutamate as one of the things that's measured.
The problem is that they're urinary test kits. And if you test urinary glutamate levels,
that is not, you cannot equate that to the levels of glutamate in the brain. So to answer, yes,
there are measurable ways to measure glutamate. But no, they're not accurate for the measurement
of neurotransmitters in the brain. So we can do a neurotransmitter test. And it's a good test because
you need neurotransmitter's throat, your body, not just your brain. But we're talking about the
damaging effects of high glutamate or problems with temperament issues and anger or depression. And
we're looking at serotonin levels and dopamine levels, urinary neurotransmitter testing falls short.
It's not an accurate picture of what is going on in the brain. So you have to look at behavior. You have
to look at genetics. And then from that, you could extrapolate. So let's say a person has a
has a familial dispensation to to dementia, okay. My my mother had dementia, my father had dementia,
my aunt had dementia, my grandmother had dementia. Oh my gosh, she knows this is running in my family.
Well, we want to look at your genetics, your DAOA genes, your glute genes, and other glutamate
genes and glutamate genes that could increase a person's glutamate levels from consumed amino acid
glutamene, which if that is the case, then we'd say, boy, you have these defects in your glutamene
genes. You are going to produce excess glutamate. It would be who you to try to push out dementia
a little farther to decrease animal proteins, go on a more plant-based diet. So what we have found
is that the glutamine in plant proteins doesn't have the exact same effects as the glutamine in animal
proteins. And I don't know why yet. I haven't found any studies that tell us why yet, but that's just
what we found clinically. So taking those people that let's say you don't even have a genetic test,
let's say we just know that you have dementia in the family, it may be a wise thing to do to go on a
more plant-based diet to decrease animal proteins because you are going to decrease glutamate levels.
However, remember, if you're going to solely decrease glutamate levels by decreasing animal proteins,
but not decreasing dietary glutamate levels, well, forget it. Well, where am I getting dietary
glutamate levels? Dietary glutamate levels are found in foods that are prepared foods.
Well, why would I have glutamates and prepared foods? Because the food industry is really smart and
they don't care about your health. If we're going to make a product and we want to sell a lot of it,
we'll load it up with glutamates. Glutamates are technically naturally, our natural substances,
so they can be listed as natural flavorings. That's when you see that on a label,
most likely it has glutamates in it. So glutamates are added to foods because glutamate is an
excitatory neurotransmitter. So it stimulates the glutamate receptors on your tongue. It is excitatory
to the neurons in your brain. Here it is excitatory. So excess glutamate causes excitotoxicity.
That was a word coined by Dr. Blaelach, I believe, that excitotoxicity, that excess excitation
of the glutamate receptors actually causes cell death of the brain, that brain cell. So over time,
constant opregulation of glutamate in the brain causes brain cell death. But what it does,
on a temporary basis, when you eat a Dorito with four different types of glutamates in it,
you taste it, you go, wow, this tastes good. I have to get some more of these. These are delicious.
And is it really good? No, it's just exciting glutamate receptors. You think it tastes good because
your brain is excited. Your brain is turned on. So that's what's really important.